[Music]
Coenen I got her in this little pouch
because she's a kangaroo species she's a
marsupial so that's what they do when
they're babies they hang out in their
mom's pouch and that keeps them safe and
they go in there and they nurse and they
actually are born almost like fetuses
they don't have fur they'll have eyes
they just have two little legs and they
are born I had to crawl into the pouch
where they know eating my microphone
well use that part of the natural order
for these it's about the same size in
the shape as her mother's nipple so
that's what she thinks is going on
they're so sad she was like Mama's
nipple and it was a microphone well it
didn't get it didn't give her anything
so she gave up on it that's the coolest
prank of all what a sweetie pie and this
is so you can these are a little
clawfoot
these are her big old kangaroo feet
that's that's her ankle right there this
is the angle this is you know her toe so
you know these animals have to be able
to hop at really really fast speeds you
kinky Oh
so this animal lives in a pouch well
when they're babies she's about five
months old anywhere from you know six
months to almost almost a year they'll
stay in that pouch do they ever if they
don't if they fail in the world move
back into their pouch no I actually
believe believe without their posters
again from college yeah believe it out
the older the older babies once the the
you know their siblings come along the
older ones still try to get back in
there for as long as they possibly can I
mean it's safe it's warm the free
transportation yeah free grub that's
what everybody wants
but but yeah you know the females as
tutors these these guys are am I making
the right sounds by the way I'm just
randomly picking noises I don't know
what will be the most soothing oh I
think it's working because she's totally
relaxed in your arms there right yeah so
yeah but these these you know the
mothers when they are being threatened
they actually do something a little bit
gruesome and that is say if a dingo is
chasing after you know one of these
Wallabies to make a meal of it and the
mother gets really stretched she will
actually push the baby out of her pouch
that's kind of a sacrificial lamb and
then she gets to go on and have another
baby so nature you know read and tooth
and claw
wait a minute the mom says uh-oh
dingo gaining on me have my baby yeah
pretty much
pretty much yeah what kind of creep I
don't know her heart years right no no
what a beautiful animal really sweet
this animal have a pouch she does
actually this is a female females have
pouches females have pouches nails done
and actually if you want to feel around
in there you might be able to find it to
read my Craigslist ad what's your
problem this is a caracal oh I was told
this was just going to be a cat it is a
cat if I'm brought a yarn and everything
this is quite a surprise it's called a
caracal you know it's like a Lynx am i
reason to say that you know it's
actually it's related you know it's a
cat so it is related to Lynx these guys
live in Africa and Asia Lynx live in you
know Europe and Asia and North America
but just pretend it's a link so I look
smart okay you can call it an African
links if you want actually that's what
these cats used to be called but they
are actually a separate species okay I
have the same kind of ear tufts at the
top of their ears there which you know
kind of helps them be camouflaged in the
you know sort of the dry grassy
environments I'm speaking to it I'm
telling it you're on Conan he's liking
some smell that's down there on the
carpet and believe it or not that's
where Andy urinate
yeah well you know what I was just gonna
say a lot of people a lot of people see
these the these gorges and medium-sized
cats and they think wow what an amazing
pet it would make but these guys have
musk glands and they pee and it's just
really not a good animal that you ever
want around in your house stick with
your domesticated cats but these guys
are predators they can actually leap you
know 1215 feet in the air they actually
catch birds out of the sky jump in the
air and catch a bird out of the sky and
then land and it's cooked by the time
they hit the bottom they don't even need
to cook it they just eat it what is
going on with the tip of the ears is
that like you did that with moose or is
that
is that happen in the wine no again a
lot of these small cat species have
these ear tufts and you know it's it's
you know potential camouflage you know
kind of breaks up their silhouette it
makes them almost look like grasses when
they're hiding
so that prey doesn't actually kind of
think that would give them away you know
they're in the grass no one sees me and
two crazy ears sticking out you'd be
surprised
oh sorry yeah he's a little spooky let's
see if we can get him to move a little
bit just realize what show it was on
come on let's see if we can this was
Helen maybe not so anyway yeah these
guys are just you know amazing predators
totally beautiful they're actually doing
okay in the wild unlike many other
species and again you know I bring all
these animals on just really to get the
message out that so many wildlife
species need our help the National
Wildlife Federation is all about
protecting wildlife so you know we can
use all the help we can get